by the time the chiefs and bucks take
the field for tomorrow's game in tampa
another team will be wrapping
up their work groundskeepers will have
spent more than a month making sure the
grassy surface is ready for the biggest
sporting event of the year
and incredibly for all 55 super bowls
the same man
has been tending the field brook silva
braga has his story
once you get a broom and follow him when
george tomah looks out at the super bowl
field he doesn't see
a giant green rectangle knock it down a
little bit
so much as he seems to fixate on every
little patch of grass
that rollers donut and see things so
many things
that can be improved what happened there
you think sand
i think we need to pull it i think so
too at 92
tomah is semi-retired ed mangan is the
lead nfl groundskeeper now
but george remains as he's been for 55
years
the irreplaceable caretaker of
football's biggest stage
in the lead-up to the game do you try to
keep people off the field
try to but there's more people on the
field
because every day you have halftime or
pre-game rehearsal
i kid around with him and i tell them
that grass grows by
inches and is killed by feet tomah is
one of fewer than 15 people to have been
at
every super bowl he credits his work
ethic and career path
to a childhood in pennsylvania coal
country when his dad died
the owner of a minor league baseball
team hired george to the grounds crew
at age 12. and i was only 16 years
old and he named me as the head ground
keeper
with grass you have pride before long he
was in the big leagues in kansas city
and it cultivated a reputation that
landed him on the cbs evening news
in 1971 his apprentices have been so
infected with his epidemic enthusiasm
that they push the heavy tarpon roll
with a zest that makes up for missing
poundage
municipal stadium mostly hosted baseball
games
but for one special night back in 1964
tomah welcomed the beatles their
dressing room was our shop
with dirt and their sand in their piles
of everything
george snuck his seven-year-old son chip
backstage it rained then the red warning
track
was wet so a tow chip hurry up and get
some poster board
you can get their footprints and they
came in all those beetles signed those
footprints when the hitting is hard but
it was the sure footing of the kansas
city chiefs
that gave tomah his biggest break this
is a good grasp
when the afl and nfl organized their
first championship game
george was asked to prepare the field at
the la coliseum
for what would be called super bowl my
equipment was
only a three by four trunk of equipment
today for the super bowl we have two
60-foot tractor trailers full of
equipment
now if you somehow forced george to pick
just one story
from the next 54 years he'd probably
start telling you
about another time in tampa 30 years ago
on the eve of super bowl 25
are you ready for war desert storm had
just begun
so they had to change all their pregame
and halftime show
to be patriotic and they practiced and
practiced so
they worn out the center of the field
the night before the game
tomah found the 50-yard line in rough
shape
i told the boys we're going to go and
get some sod they said they laughed at
me
were you going to get sad at six o'clock
at night
i says just follow me we'll get sod
george drove to the university of tampa
this
is where it all happened at the time
this stretch of dirt was a soccer field
and there was a gate like that
a chain-link gate george's
co-conspirator
pointed out a problem he said the gates
locked i said
darn right it's like grabbed this s-o-b
so he rammed it and we started taking
assad along the fence
now this was all a surprise to jerome
fulton
i heard this man's feelings a little bit
he was
and is the university groundskeeper so i
get here monday morning and there's a
hole in the field and a gate that's
broken
but the sod was cut out so nicely it
wasn't vandalism
we played in the super bowl at least my
turf did
the tour for tomorrow's game spent 18
months growing in georgia
it'll soon be subjected to a hundred
pairs of cleats
tons of stage equipment and hundreds of
millions of critical eyes
but the lines came out good and if the
condition of the field
never gets mentioned tonight george
tomah we'll be proud
tell you why you can putt on it now for
cbs this morning saturday brook silva
bracket
new york i never realized what it took
to prepare that field it's painstaking
and he does such a fantastic that was
i was awesome great job great job
yeah phenomenal story that i didn't know
about until next year
how about that